for maxat which is then the last talk
for today uh before the reception please
okay thank you um I want to first start
by introducing the terms in the title so
that release the title was
understandable
this is working with Ariana tan who's
unfortunately not here in Stefan who's
here as well
so
um
I think most people here know about Max
it is but just let's quickly go with the
definitions we're given a set of heart
Clauses and a set of soft clauses
and this of course is usually have
weights or they can be unweighted which
means uniform weights um
and be looking for a solution that sets
us all the hard Clauses so the heart
causes alone or a satisfability problem
and then we want to satisfy as many of
the softwares as possible
um in the sense that the sump weight of
the satisfied software should be
maximized or the other way around we
want to minimize the cost so we want to
minimize the summed weight of the
unsatisfied
Flores in the talk before we can see the
soft classes as a linear optimization
goal and very different views on the
same topic
and
but we're what we were interested in
finding a different approach for
incomplete Microsoft solving so um we
want to have an anytime server we want
to quickly have some solution that might
not be optimal and we want to
continuously improve this so whenever
the user stops this over it we have a
solution
um and this means that we have no
guarantee of optimality so even if we
find open resolution we might not know
that it's optimal so we really like try
and try and try again until we are
interrupted for some reason
and we want to do this with with a
method we call sub-based local
Improvement which we use quite often so
it's uh we Define a structure for the
problem that we can use for for our
solution
and so that so our basic idea is we want
to use some complete solver inside our
heuristic algorithm or use case or
anytime algorithm
and this usually requires a specific
structure that that can be used for the
server
and so we have we assume we have some
some sub-optimal solutions and inputs so
there's some Oracle that gives us some
solution replica is an input then we
repeatedly use the structure we
originally defined to find like the
smaller part of the instance that is
small enough so we can keep it to a
complete solver and get hopefully some
better small solution
and then we have some mechanism that
reintegrates this this improved solution
in our Global solution and we've solved
our immune so but we have looked at sat
servers Microsoft servers PDF solvers
SMP servers to the Boolean server so
this whole family of kind of sat related
servers
and we have used this for decision tree
minimization for patient Network
structure learning for graph
decompositions for you know circuit
minimization for graph colorings and so
on so
by now it's a very very widely applied
technique and I can really recommend
anybody who wants and anytime algorithm
for some optimization problem to kind of
check out the related work
um so just to make this very loaded
previous slide more clear so how does it
work we have an initial solution would
be getting our steam algorithm and then
we do the three steps over and over we
expect some local instance that we pass
to our solver and either we find no
improvement and we just try the next
local instance or we integrate a local
solution and again start to look all
over again and you see it's kind of an
infinite Loop so we iterate until we are
stopped
um so how to define a local instance in
Microsoft and this is not our idea this
has been done before it will come back
to this so we just look at the limited
set of variables so we divide our set of
variables into fixed and three variables
and we say we cannot change the fixed
variables in a local instance
and then we can basically what we get
from these are assumptions so everybody
who is familiar with assumptions so we
we say the fixed variables are
assumptions which means we can
immediately remove all the instances
that are satisfied under the fixed
variables from our instance and they can
remove the variable the the fixed
variables from all the remaining Clauses
because then there are falsified
literals uh and then we probably get
some unit Clauses which we can use for
unit propagation and then the resulting
Clause the representing instance will be
much smaller than the original one and
then we can give it to our Max that's
over
um to get an improved solution and if we
find an improved solution for this small
instance it's automatically together
with the fixed variables and improve
solution for the overall Maxwell
instance and we repeat this and repeat
this until
um we are stopped for a timeout or a
limited number of operations or the user
Interrupters as are small example so we
have an initial assignment in the left
upper corner which sets all the
variables except the last to false we
want to fix variables to and four which
means the other ones are free
so um
so we first remove all the classes that
are satisfied you see the gaps on the
right hand side and then we remove all
the falsified literals which already
means that our instance is quite a bit
smaller uh then we have a unit class so
with unit propagation we get a much much
smaller instance and then if you look at
the instance we can set either V3 or B5
to true but not both which means that
since B5 was already
set to true in the initial assignment we
cannot really improve upon our solution
in this case but we could vary it so it
might also benefit to just set me three
to two and see what happens in our
algorithm further on
so this uh and destruction we will use
is the primograph so the paramigraph is
the vertex for each variable and two
vertices are connected if the associated
variables are current sum uh Clause
together yeah so we can see B1 occurs
with all variables in some class but
before only occurs 51 and we choose so
there is no Edge to the bus and B3
um so this this idea this basically tier
has been done in the paper last year by
hiki and tacos
um so they use an incomplete Max that's
over from the competition
to get an initial solution and then what
they do to select the variables is they
assign a way to each variable occurs in
the soft class and this the way depends
on if the software is satisfied or not
and then they perform uniform uh
weighted sampling weighted sampling to
get the set of fixed variables
and uh then they then they reduce the
instances from before and give it to the
Max and server and they do this over and
over again
and the experiments show that they can
actually beat uh the the best income
bits over from the competition using
this
and this is a very neat approach
um really liked it and it's very closely
related to slim
but we thought okay so because they
don't assign any way to variables on the
current soft process so basically apart
from these variables everything else is
chosen randomly and this kind of ignores
a lot of information that you can get by
the instance so before the cake if you
can put this in a more structured way
maybe we can improve upon this method
and what I mean with structure so here
is the primograph of a rather small
instance uh the brown vertices are fixed
variables and the blue vertices are
three variables and you can see that
kind of this is all over the place
although you can see that the instances
structure the free variables are all
over the place and there's no
discernible pattern behind it
um so where we started from is if you
give me an assignment to a market
instance that I should improve
um what I have to do is I have to
satisfy an additional software there's
no way around it okay so
um we think we thought okay we start
with some unsatisfied soft Clauses under
the assignment we already have
and we add variables from there because
we have to flip some variables in answer
the unsatisfied soft Clauses so why not
start there
um but now if I have a if if I said one
of the reposes free I don't know its
value anymore because it's really can be
changed and we reflect this by removing
these variables from all the clauses
because we don't know the value anymore
and then we get more anti-thestratic
Clauses because if the variable was used
to satisfy the first Sunday the class is
unsatisfied
and then we add variables from these
answers to our free variables because we
need to satisfy them as well to be able
to set to to satisfy the softballs in
the beginning and we do this step over
and over again
picking uh variables from from
unsatisfied Clauses and then removing
the free variables from all the other
classes
until we hit some boundary because we
don't want our new instance to be too
big and we want to happen very small so
we can repeatedly column accessor on
this model instance
and then
um implicitly what this construction
does it it explores the primer graph
right so we have the the variables in
the soft Clauses are vertices we add
them and then we look at the
neighborhood of the vertices that we
have in our three type in the set of
three by openness
um so here's this and here's an example
so now it's the same example as before
but I call it the colored the Clauses
depending if they're satisfied in green
or unsatisfied in red
and so we see that the there's only one
software satisfied so it's rather low
score
and but of course all the hard courses
are satisfied it's a it's a feasible
solution
so we pick a variable from a soft class
and first step we pick V1 uh we remove
it from all the classes and now suddenly
we have two we have three unsatisfied
hard clauses
okay do the same thing again we pick a
variable from one of the unsatisfied
hard courses like speak V2
um again another unsatisfied Clause
um we pick another variable
um now almost all the articles are
unsatisfied
um and now we say okay for some reason
we want to stop with three three where
three three variables and we stop and be
construct construct a local instance
so now uh before and before fixed so we
remove all the satisfied Clauses by the
assignment to be four and B5 which
leaves these gaps and be removed V4 and
V5 from all clauses
so now we have a smaller instance and
since we have no unit classes unit
propagation doesn't reduce this instance
further
but we can quickly see that if we can
actually set B2 and V3 to true in this
uh smaller instance and then together
with V5 which is fixed we would get an
assignment with three satisfied soft
losses so we can improve with this
smaller instance
so the question is what where we've
successful so the first question is like
does this actually explore the structure
better than the LNS approach and if you
look at this visualization you see it
clearly yes
so I don't understand how you can have
V1 V2 V3 in that example because the
first Clause was
that they have it leaves one of them has
to be false
you haven't satisfied all three of the
soft clauses
we're trying to get Max no no these are
this is the instance so we like because
we foreign B5 are fixed they're not
anymore in the in the in the smaller
instance
but these are the soft Clauses of the of
the local instance so it's I like we
want to maximize the number of satisfied
variables
well it doesn't satisfy the first
one of these soap it will be better than
before
want to satisfy all of them so we kind
of assume we cannot set this by all of
them
because otherwise this would just be sad
but we assume okay we cannot say it's
like oh we just want to maximize the
number of variables
but your soft spots are unit sorry yes
sorry that was maybe the important
information so we we so
um these are like five unit calls the
same V1 between 45
well it's not the solution it's just the
the very this is not showing you the
solution so you haven't set B1 b2v3 I
said that's what you're allowed to set
now you're allowed to set V1 V2 V3 and
we're going to set it we still have to
satisfied all the hard Clauses so you'll
maybe set B2 and B3 to true and V1
defaults and then you get all the
classes
what
um so if you look at uh how our area
from the next instances we can see we
now clearly see the structure of the
instance reflected in our selection
particularly comparison next to each
other you can see that while the left
one on the LNS right rather random like
power is really kind of fixed up on the
clustering inside but why do you think
it's better
um
so the reason why we thought it's better
is the question was I was asking why is
a more nasty looking picture on the
right better than more massive pictures
it's a nicer picture right it's a very
good question so actually like just that
it that it looks nicer if you want it
it's not better
um so the reason why we thought it would
be better is because
um what we what if you would do Locus
that you would like flip Parables and
then you have like unsatisfied calls you
have to flip in that in those closets
and so forth and that's exactly what
we're doing but like instead of like
flipping just one variable we kind of
look at different branches
all at once
and this kind of coincides with with
doing it this way
but like if you do it just randomly all
over the instance you never guaranteed
that the variables that you select are
actually in summary related and not kind
of the propagations are blocked by
variables you don't pick in the middle
so and then with selecting this you kind
of guarantee that there's like some way
this could propagate from one variable
to the other if you change the value
so that was the that is the the idea why
we why we looked at this
make sense
um so we wanted to check if this is
actually better if this performs better
so we we set up some experiments and we
oriented our experiments around
um how the backside regulation is done
so there uh the scoring is to divide the
best result by the server results so if
you find the tester starting to get one
point and the closer you get the zero
diversity result
um so the original and implementation by
Linkin Park was used Max HSS Max over so
we use the same for better comparability
and um so there are a lot of
implementation details that kind of not
in this talk
um but we just used one configuration
for all the experiments we're not cherry
picking them on different configurations
um and the way we set this up is we take
the best server from the last year's
maxit evaluation new table LS
and we let it run for a given timeout
but after an initial time of the pass
the current solution to LNS into our
implementation and we let them run to
the end and then we checked which of the
solvers performed better so we need an
input solution that we get from this
Implement server but we also wanted to
know does it actually improve upon just
running this over to the end
um and we did we we chose like time
after five minutes because that's what
the market evaluation uses and 30
minutes because we were interested in
but how does it behave if you let it run
for longer
so this is the result for the animated
instances and then what what you can see
is that actually the if you take the
average score of all instances then our
implementation is a bit worse than the
than the state of the art server but it
still beats LNS but more interesting to
me was that okay we can actually improve
upon more instances so it's just that
um on the instances where new double LS
is better it's just Source way higher
um so
uh so it's not clearly better but
there's a clear advantage on several
instances
um and then if you let it run for longer
this this becomes even more pronounced
which is not surprising because at some
point the the the the income be server
will run out of things to look at and
then any change will probably perform
better but we provide significantly
better than the LLS approach
so I would say from this from these
results clearly using a structured
approach over just random as an
advantage
um
yes one question as best solution you
are using the best solution of these
solvers or you were incorporating the
solutions of all the solvers for the
Microsoft if you remember correctly we
use the best solution from our
experiments and the best solution from
the access computation so the overall
minimum solution okay thank you
yes just I'm just missing something
quiet
why are there fewer improved in the 30
minutes oh sorry um so if you look at
this so this initial timeout is one
minute uh for the five minute timer on
five minutes that's why
um
and then if you look at the weighted
instances
um kind of it's it's similar but this
difference between
um how many instances we can improve in
comparison to the Maxis over itself
becomes even more pronounced and also
the difference in the average score
between MLS and our implementations also
are clearly better
so the conclusion um so what I wanted to
show in this talk is it just this
general idea of of this uh LNS approach
in a structured manner is a promising
way to look at it and there's a lot of
potential for for for improvement
um there are several implementation
issues for example like passing the
local instances to the Max and silver is
a there's a performance bottleneck
uh there might be silver combinations
that work better than what we use we
just try to make it more as comparable
to LNS as possible but just check if
using a structure approach really
improves
um and then it was actually very hard to
integrate a lot of film access
particularly the incomplete uh solvers
and I would say the main probably
because it's optimized for the
competition and competition setting is
not the setting we will use
um so I hope that
um there will be is like some I don't
hope more people could pick up on this
use use this over symptom there's a bit
more encouragement to actually optimize
the server to these use cases
um some interesting open questions is uh
where like I talked to a few people here
already and then the first somebody said
it can you can you put this into a Maxis
over directly like by wrap it around and
they call it like this can you put this
logic into a Max direction to Max it's
over to get some improvements
um an open question is we tried to find
out but we couldn't really figure out
why and when does it work really well so
we looked at Community structures we
didn't explain it
um there are some instances we know you
kind of need to look at the whole
instance of finding Improvement where we
cannot uh we cannot do well but there
there seems to be some something going
on that become a kind of pinpoint yet
and then so we use the primer graph as a
structure but there are other structures
uh you can use for the for such
instances and then I think an
interesting way to go is the class is
there a better structure than what we
used
so thank you for your attention
so you are using a complete solver so
you aren't getting an incomplete solver
and then inside your Loop you're a
complete solver is this because of the
technical difficulties yes so so I spent
like yeah there's some technical
difficulties then the nice thing about
Max HS is for computer it often gives
you a supporting resolution as well so
even if you plan to stop it you often
get a good Solution that's not optimal
anywhere so it's kind of not anytime but
often has any kind of behavior so it
kind of worked well within our framework
I would lead us to understand better why
there are different I mean technical
difficulties right maybe yeah it would
like to talk to you about it
yeah I have a question so you probably
saw that for complete solvers there is
this now tendency to run a mips over as
a kind of a press solver for five
minutes and then run for whatever like
certain amount of time and this really
you find the winner for the competition
so I was wondering is it 70 check did
you try to run mips over uh or or tools
and see what's about they will give you
after the same time out oh that would be
interesting it's actually so what what
usually happens when you when you look
at what what does
um so the Microsoft server for the sub
course usually returns very quickly so
we actually get a lot of Microsoft posts
going on
oh
it's easy to find some solution but it's
not easy to find the optimal solution
right
um yes but so you can just an
inconveniences it's not clear how far
away from the optimal solution we just
know how far away we are from the best
known solution so yeah what I'm just
saying is
or even Skip and see uh in the same time
timeout what will be the upper balance
that it needs you it will be alternative
for the incomplete right
this might be a knife question but uh
there's some classical work on using
randomized rounding for Max set right
um
with some probabilistic guarantees about
how approximation guarantees about it
how close it can be to the optimal okay
so I'm just wondering does it make sense
to you some of that in your
approach
I have to I would have to look at the
work I'm not that from the deal with it
um
maybe we can discuss something very
happy to
the other question
with incremental accessories help yes I
think I think incremental marketers
would kind of alleviate the bottleneck
of making this this uh this up calls
because you would have to instantiate
this over once and then pass just ask
your local instance assumptions
basically right but it would have been
kind of unfair to compare that with the
LNS approach but it didn't use it all
right well it could be easily plugged in
yes
about the rounding thing I I think they
would not work as well as the
we tried something at some point for
funding yeah
I'm I would be pessimistic about it but
you can fool me wrong
I have a general comment if I may sorry
could we please start defining Microsoft
as just a linear objective function
subject to a set of clauses
just a suggestion because that's how the
solvers view the instances yeah but it's
kind of it depends on like what people
have heard before I think if you try to
put in all three definitions you know
you really cumbersome to talk about this
so you know soft process and there can
be ways
because the solvers don't really work
like I agree with them
I think if I am also allowed to come we
discuss this with the Arabia already I
think it depends on whether you want in
in a community like like you're not
going to change how theoreticians talk
about Microsoft that's just not gonna
happen okay and so if you want them to
understand your talk then you have to go
through these hoops probably I guess if
but if you go to the set conference I
guess this is already like you get the
definition okay minimize this then
you're objective subject to The Sinner
no it's not but it's like if you're not
their own community
foreign
hey so then I think let's thank Andre
again
and now hopefully there should be some
kind of
reception let's go out and find out
together
um